[Music]
hello everyone and welcome back to chess
openings explained as always my name is
caleb denvey
and tonight i am going to be taking you
through yet another opening lecture
on the f3 nimzo we are
nearing the end of this series uh we
have covered many
many many of the main most popular lines
but one in particular has avoided my
attention
so far and that is the line where black
immediately plays c5
in response to the f3 nimzo now i have
sort of been intentionally avoiding this
because
this uh c5 variation is
one of the most difficult both for white
and for
black they just arise in really complex
positions that could go any number of
ways and i wasn't sure how i wanted to
cover it
but i think i have a pretty good idea of
what i want to talk about tonight
the reason why 4c5 i think is so
difficult to get a good grasp on
is that there are really a variety of
structures in a variety of ways
that the game can turn and so it can be
difficult to understand
which of those you should be aiming for
defend depending on the specifics
so before we jump into sort of the main
variations
where everything is pretty fluid and
where white and black both have a pretty
strong say
in which direction the game is going to
go i want to look at
some slightly less popular variations
that are still
very much worth knowing but the reason
they're less popular
is because the structure of the game
sort of is determined a little bit
earlier and by looking at these
we're gonna have a better understanding
when later in the lecture i get to the
more mainline stuff
so to start off with i have a game from
the 1990s actually
this used to be i think a very very
common way
that people played against the f3 nimzo
but in this sense died off because i
just don't think the positions are very
good for black
so players with the black pieces sort of
stop doing it so let's take a look here
we start with d4 knight f6 c4
e6 knight c3 of course bishop b4
f3 and then our topic of choice tonight
is this move for c5 the dark squared
plan
so black makes no attempt to fight for
the e4 square as we saw in the d5
variations
and instead looks to challenge the pawn
on d4
challenge the dark squares and sort of
bait white into playing this move
of d5 now this is by far the most common
move for white and it's what i'm going
to suggest
but there is another option here to play
the move a3 directly
that being said this scores very well
for black and perhaps we'll see
why in light of our first variation
today so
if you want sort of the same game every
time though and you don't feel like
learning all this stuff on c5 i would
recommend checking out a3
because more often than not your games
are going to go like this and
things start to get a little bit more
more linear so you can't really
get this wide variety of positions that
you can get from the main line
that being said i do think this is just
a good position for black
after for example knight c6 and
and d6 now why is that when compared
with something we looked at earlier
which was
um in yesterday's lecture we looked at a
knight e8 sort of variation and what
happens if black leaves the knight on f6
and the reason why this is worse than
that other variation is because
for example after knight c6 e4 d6
in the other variations we were sort of
in time to play this move bishop d3 and
this really does make a difference in a
lot of the positions
whereas here we're just a couple tempi
short of where
where we used to be right we can no
longer play bishop d3 because this pawn
is simply hanging and development
just is is pretty awkward for white now
it's not an awful variation and it's a
perfectly acceptable way to play
if you don't feel like learning
everything after d5
so i did want to give it a brief mention
here but just
for the purposes of our lecture we're
going to focus on this move d5
and from here black really does have a
variety of ways to play
but the first one we're going to look at
is the move
bishop takes c3 this is sort of of
course you know very much the more
the most direct way for black to play
black very much
forces the structure right off the bat
and that's what i mean
when i say it takes away a lot of the
fluidity there's no more
sort of question about which direction
the game is going to go black is
deciding right here and now
this is the structure for me the problem
is
of course that this is sort of a waste
of a tempo just playing bishop takes c3
unprovoked
it's rarely the best idea and i think
that sort of principle holds true here
white is going to use that extra tempo
and get a pretty good position
so b takes c3 and now uh the games are
really going to take shape with this
move d6
and in this game we see the immediate
move e5 right this is the structure
that black was aiming for and it's the
structure that that black gets it no
longer really makes sense by the way
to be going for any e takes d5 stuff
because
our second c pawn is going to come in
handy there and white should be
much better so e5 instead
and now again we're going to play this
move bishop d3
in the game yesterday continued with
knight bd7
which by the way there's another uh fun
game from about 10 years
prior to this in 1983 where yasser was
playing this with white and sort of got
crushed by old fanderson
so maybe yasser had you know bad
memories of this with the white side and
wanted to give it a try with the black
side
unfortunately for yasser it did not go
his way either time
now in this game we see knight e2
and the most popular move here is knight
to
f8 black can also consider playing h6
but white's response is going to be the
same against knight f8 or h6
the move i'm going to recommend is the
move h4
now why is this to understand why this
move is being played here
i think it is actually useful to refer
back to yasser's
you know past game against olf anderson
so
ulf played h6 against yasser and then
yasser included
the move knight g3 and a little bit
later on
we'll see that white castle's king side
and black
actually expands with g5 now yasser had
a very back and forth double-edged game
and had chances here
but black had this active plan of coming
after white's king on the king's side
thanks to this move g5 so h4 sort of
puts a stop to the that kind of thinking
before it ever gets started
and i think it's a great way to uh to
play
um okay
we just did that thing where it mixes
all the variations but we're back on
track
so h6 is the move played in this game
and i think this is the best move
for black for some reason this move h5
is appearing in more games but i just
don't think this is a very good move
white can occupy the g5 square and
black's best try
is to force the bishop back and then
sort of lose time
like this and with the move h5 you're
going to get very very similar positions
to what we'll see in the game
but black just sort of has one more weak
square to uh to worry about so not my
favorite idea
we're going to focus on h6 in this case
bishop e3
knight g6 played in the game queen d2
and now yasser plays the move uh king
to d7 and
from here we're gonna see sort of the
problem
for black in in the game and in these
positions in general and and that is
black is just unable to come up with a a
a good plan there's just no strategic
plan for black in these positions
and uh black is sort of just gonna have
to wait and be at the mercy of the
player with the white pieces so
here yasser plays a strange looking move
king d7 because the center
is so so blocked off that it doesn't
really matter if black castles or not
and black is going to aim to put the
king over here on
the queen side or leave it on a square
like c7 where it's going to be perfectly
safe
now in the game we see white just castle
queenside
yasser comes out with queen a5 we see
king b2 now
king c7 king a1 and bishop d7 so
yasser finally sort of quote unquote
finishes development with bishop d7 of
course this bishop
isn't doing that much more than it was
on c8s
and from here the game sort of took
a long long time to get to where it was
going and i'm not sure that either
player really played with the utmost
accuracy
but the point is for our opening
discussion
this is pretty much where the opening
ends now i'm gonna
continue on a little bit and discuss
sort of how white should aim to open
things up favorably
but as far as openings go this is sort
of the end of the line here you don't
really have to memorize all these moves
h4 is the important idea to know and
then i do think that a1 is actually the
best
the best square for white's king from
here though we are going to see
that black is sort of just helplessly
shuffling around
while white aims to find some way to
break through
so obviously this is a dynamic that is
going to favor the player with the white
pieces
if white can't find a way to break
through then white will also shuffle and
the game will be a draw
if white does find some way to break
through then black is in big trouble and
is likely going to lose
the game so that is sort of the
character of the position
that being said there were a lot more
moves rook b1 was played b6
uh rook b3 which is sort of an odd move
to me
sort of hinting at doubling but not a
huge deal
queen a6 h5 by white now takes even more
space and removes this knight from the
nice g6 square
where it eyes the f4 square uh knight e7
was played
now bishop f2 uh knight to h7 and
here i am going to divert from the game
in the game there was a lot more
shuffling with knight g3
and the game just took ages and ages and
ages
so much shuffling all over the board and
you're perfectly allowed to play like
that but already here white had a chance
to be much much better with the move f4
and after f4 white is simply looking to
take on e5
open up this file and get a past d-pawn
so black should probably play the move
f6
preparing to capture back on e5 with the
f-pawn
now it's important to understand that
white should not be too hasty
in actually opening up files it's fine
to create this tension with the pawn on
f4
but actually opening up the f file is
going to allow blackstrikes into the
game
and so here white should continue just
developing slowly for example bishop e3
rook hf8 rook g1 rick 88 for
example it's sort of difficult to come
up with concrete ideas
for black and now after g4 queen c8
white has a number of ways to continue
but perhaps the most fun
is the rather surprising move knight d4
which you
you might not expect to be playable here
but is actually going to be quite strong
and the point now for white is that
knight f5 is
is coming very very directly on the next
turn
and white is is going to be much better
after knight f5 threats of g5 are always
going to be in the air threats of taking
here
and sacking on h6 white is just much
better in
the position notably if you take this
this is a rather bad idea white's going
to take back
and just an example line now if takes
then
takes king b8 for example bishop takes
b6 is in the air maybe king b7
but now queen a5 and black is sort of
just checkmated these knights are never
coming back to the queen side
and black is in big big trouble
same thing if you take here by the way
still c takes d4
and if you don't take here then i am
going to take
on c5 same sorts of issues here
for black same sorts of issues just sort
of getting checkmated
so knight d4 would be a nice find here
that being said
white is also better after a4 a4 for
example
the point i'm trying to get across is
that white is having all the fun in
these positions black just has no active
plan
and white can sort of proceed at their
leisure
no need to play f4 and g4 right away you
can take all the time in the world
and eventually more often than not i
think black's
position is going to crumble okay
so what was the point of all this the
point of this was to show what's
happening
in these positions where black takes on
c3
so here we saw that this structure in
particular when white has really made no
concessions
tends to be good for white white wants
to play
h4 and keep the king's side locked down
and aside from that white's not really
going to have any issues in
this particular structure okay
with that any questions on this
particular opening line or structure
before i move on
any questions here
all right well let us move along
yeah great wolf asked does black have to
worry about h5 kicking the knight on g6
and we did see eventually uh
h5 does come by white it's not as if
it's a huge threat or anything
it's just that white is able to take a
little bit more space
notably in those lines where black plays
h5 white also has an additional idea
of g4 to pressure the h5 pawn and can
also just target it with
with pieces as well
and yeah andrew says is there a way for
black to exploit the double pawns and so
that's a great question
this particular variation sort of
differs from other lines of the nemzo
where we've seen this double pawn
structure because there really is no
good way for white to or for black to
attack these for example you can try
queen a5 here
but just the simple move bishop d2
and we're going to get something very
very similar to what we've already seen
you can try to put a knight on e5 but it
is going to be very very difficult
to apply much more pressure and if you
don't play the move e5 you may regret it
eventually
with white taking over on some dark
squares as well
for example with the move f4 coming
rather shortly
in other variations we saw black go for
a knight a5 b6 bishop a6 sort of deal
but with these pawns already committed
here that plan
is sort of sort of in the past no longer
really going to be an idea
for black okay good questions let us
move on
to the next kind of structure that i
want to talk about which is going to
happen
in this game between surya ganguly
and morteza majoub
so let's see what's going on here we
have d5 or d4
we get the nimzo indian c5 once again d5
once again
and now we're going to start with the
immediate b5
so this is the way for black to apply
the most immediate pressure to c4
now in comparison with the last line
that we looked at this one is a bit more
popular and a bit more recent as well
appearing in games between
lavon aronian magnus carlson lexy shirov
kramnik
eliana of harikrishna they all have
games in this
position so what's the point of the
immediate b5
well we're going to see this idea crop
up in almost every main variation
for black and the point is that of
course you are not so interested in
capturing this pawn
at the expense of your d5 pawn either
knight takes or pawn takes are both very
strong here
for black so
white is going to play the move e4 and
defend this pawn
a little bit more thoroughly later in
the lecture
after this variation we're going to talk
about what happens after castles
that gets into the more mainline type of
variations
where things are sort of in flux both
players sort of jockeying to figure out
which type of position
is going to favor them but for now let's
take a look at the most forcing
pawn takes c4 this is sort of the second
type of structure
that's going to be really important in
this c5 variation
and many many cases black is going to be
able to take on c4
and white is going to take back with the
bishop
and from here black is going to take on
d5 in most cases the idea of b
takes c4 is to weaken white's control of
d5
so it's the most sensible to follow this
up with an immediate capture on
d5 so in this variation where black
takes immediately black almost always
takes on d5
that being said it's not necessarily
forced later on as we'll see
but here we're going to start with the
capture on d5 and black can actually
insert a little bit of a trick here
with knight takes d5 so of course the
idea
is that if the pawn takes then queen h4
check is going to pick up the bishop and
black will be better
so regardless knight takes or pawn takes
either way you're going to take this
back with the bishop
we see pawn takes d5 and now we
definitely
don't want to play pawn takes d5 giving
ourselves a weak d5 pawn
and opening up the e file a little bit
prematurely also
still allowing some ideas of something
like this but the move queen takes d5
is going to be the move for white here
so this
is the second really important structure
that we're going to find happens
uh quite often black takes on c4 and
then takes on d5
to sort of achieve this structure so
what's going on here uh
at first glance it seems like black is
is sort of close to losing a rook of
course there's the move knight c6
uh but aside from that
what's happening well we'll see in this
case
that this structure is sort of what it
appears
it's more compact for white and black is
going to be facing a couple weaknesses
here
on d7 and on c5 of course also the d5
square for the moment belongs to white
and that's going to be relevant in many
cases when white is trying to put a
knight onto d5
so for the moment this structure should
favor white so why does black go for
this well black is aiming to get a sort
of immediate counter play
with the pieces right white took time
to play the move f3 e4 d5 all these
moves
and now black is going to try to punish
white for leaving the king in the center
like this
a little bit too long so knight c6
should be played
by black and it most often is
and now we're going to look at the main
line of knight to e2
white sort of prepares castling in many
variations
also defends this knight in c3 again and
also prevents the
nasty idea of knight to d4
and now once again we are going to look
at the main line
which is bishop a6 this is really the
best way for black to try to prove
anything here
because like i said if black does just
castle normally
then white is fine to castle as well
and in the long term if white gets the
pieces out this is just a good structure
for white
black has more weaknesses white has more
central control
and white should be better so bishop a6
is the main idea
and the you know the point is not so
subtle right the point is
uh black wants to stop castling thanks
to this bishop bishop's pressure along
the long diagonal here
bishop takes pawn takes would lose a
knight and knight takes would lose
a rook so with bishop a6 this is sort of
black's only attempt to stop light from
just achieving that better structure
that more comfortable position
the problem here and the reason i think
why this isn't so popular with black is
that
black has sort of committed this
structure a little bit too early
now the main move here is actually king
f2 but
surya in this game i think finds an
excellent excellent idea
that sort of makes this variation you
know very hard to justify
with the black pieces and that move
is a3 uh of course the most popular
moves king f2 and bishop e3
but sergey's move a3 i think is the most
forcing the easiest to understand and
sort of the most direct and i think it
gets uh to an
advantageous position for white so
what's not to like
uh and the point now is that we are
challenging this bishop on b4
uh actually before black has completed
development
now why does that matter because in the
next few moves if you play something
like king f2
black is going to castle and
go bishop a5 and now this pawn on c5
is sort of uncapturable and we're gonna
have this slightly weak king
now is this position better for white i
think it does tend to be a little bit
better
but you know black still has these
positional boons these these positional
benefits
right so with the immediate a3
what white is doing is forcing black to
reckon with this c5 pawn
before we commit this king to f2 before
we allow these bishop b6 tactics
now if bishop a5 were to be played white
can very seriously just capture on c5
and b up a pawn black does have some
compensation for it of course
thanks to the bishop pair in these open
diagonals
but a pawn is upon and white is is going
to simply be better
in this position uh also notably
i mentioned that black is not castled
yet and that is going to make a
difference here black is
going to have to fight for the right to
castle here if bishop b6 for example
queen d6 if bishop c set c7
now black is able to castle but as we
can see
white is able to castle as well with the
lack of the bishop on b6
so that's a very long way of saying
bishop a5 isn't a great move
if black is committed to making this
early
b take c4 take on d5 idea work then
really bishop takes
c3 should be played here as it has been
almost every time
in this position now white is going to
take back with the knight on c3
and once again black is now met with
some difficulty
guarding this c5 pawn can't really play
d6 while the knight hangs
and so that is why all the players with
the black pieces arrived at the same
conclusion
that queen to b6 should be played
now paradoxically it seems sort of
counterintuitive to put your king on f2
right after queen b6 has been played but
that's what surya does
and i think it's the best move now
surya's opponent
plays the most natural move c for check
and
we see that white does in fact actually
have one weakness in the position
and that is this pawn on b2 and this is
going to be something that appears
very very often in uh in these types of
structures black
tries to get counterplay on b2 as well
as the king
so for that reason bishop e3 i think
just isn't a very good move
but surya is
by by no stretch of the imagination a
coward and plays the move
king g3 and you get this strange looking
position
where the this is a very very safe
square for white's king
generally whenever your king is running
out in front of your pawns you're doing
quite badly
but here this knight really has no path
to attack the king this bishop is now
sort of shut out of the game
and any check on these dark squares
is now going to be met by bishop f4 and
this king is just
perfectly safe sergi's opponent actually
castles king's side here but i did want
to mention
that queen b8 check tries to be clever
to
keep in mind these threats of queen
takes b2 but now that the king is no
longer getting checked bishop f4 is
perfectly fine
and after queen to um queen takes b2
now rook h to c1 makes some threats of
trapping the queen
queen b6 for example and now knight a4
was played rook
uh was played in the only game where
this appeared but rick ab1 is
just close to winning for um for white
bishop d6 is going to follow
knight b5 ideas his king is stuck in the
center and white is
very close to winning so king side
castles is a little bit more
reasonable by majoub we see knight a4
now kicking this queen
queen a5 and now knight c5 and
this is just going to be a position now
where white's extra central space
is felt b2 is a little bit weak but
really it's not going to be a huge deal
and black is going to be the one
sort of playing catch-up defending these
weaknesses here
for example in the game rick fc 8 was
played bishop d2
queen check bishop f4 uh queen b6 now
bishop d6
and i think it's pretty clear to see
that white is
is doing a little bit better uh once
again
queen takes b2 is going to be ill
advised this time okay
the bishop's just hanging sorry in the
game
rook d8 was played again just keeping an
eye on this d7 pawn
and from here surya just went on to win
a pretty easy game eventually by the way
h4 gets played and this is the the white
king's path
back to being behind the pawns on the
king's side
but uh really just no problems at all
for
uh for white here now i do want to move
along i don't think we need to see the
rest of this game
uh as far as plans go white can attack
on the king's side
but as i've been saying it's it's really
these weaknesses that are a huge problem
in black's position and white can just
play with the pieces just
active pieces in the center of the board
what's not to like
so questions on this before i move along
to some more mainline stuff
and yes steve says that's an incredibly
bad pawn structure for black
and i agree which is why you know black
only really goes for this
to get that immediate counter play
against the white king in the center of
the board
and that's why this line by syria i
think is just a a great response it
sort of neutralizes that dark squared
bishop right off the bat and after that
bishop is gone
the structural deficits really do start
to tell
okay let us move along then to some more
mainline stuff i want to start
with a version of the main line that
includes this move b
takes c4 that we just took a look at now
this one isn't from any game in
particular
but we'll see that it follows really the
the main path
that we're going to look at tonight so
let's jump into it here
we see d4 knight f6 c4 e6
knight c3 we get d5
and i'm going to start with this move d6
notably black can also start with
castling and then play the move d6 and
arrive at the same position we're going
to be talking about
now i do want to take this opportunity
to say that i'm not going to be covering
the move b5
in this lecture it's not the most common
for black first of all it's
i think sort of the second it's sort of
secondary or even tertiary compared to
all the other options that black has
but this is another one that is going to
result in some pretty unique structures
that i'm just going to have to talk
about next time we just won't have time
to go over all the difficulties here
why doesn't black play b5 more often
well it allows the move e5 by white
and then this just gets into total
absurd craziness
so stay tuned for next lecture on that
one but first we're going to talk about
the position after castles and d6 which
is definitely the most common way
players with the black pieces uh play
this variation
so now in similar positions
we have seen that white is playing the
move bishop to
d3 um
in this case though i think the move
knight e2 is a little bit more accurate
now let's try to understand why 92
is more accurate well let's refer back
to that game we just saw between surya
game
surya ganguly and morteza majoub in
that game we saw black immediately play
b5 and b
take c4 so now that we have this one
structure
sort of in the back of our head here we
can use that in this position to say
well
i know this is one idea for black i know
black has this one idea of playing b5
and taking on c4
so should i develop my bishop or not and
in this case i don't think white
should and what is black's response
going to be well of course it's going to
be b5
why is it going to be b5 well black has
very much improved
on our previous variation white has now
wasted a full tempo
to get a very very similar position so
this is not going to be
as good for white as we saw in the
previous game
and that's why i wanted to start it
start with those two
sort of examples of slightly less common
lines
but because you know now we have sort of
a baseline for understanding these
structures
we can use that information sort of in
our main variations here
so rather than bishop d3 which is
playable it's fine for white it has been
played many times
uh instead i'm going to recommend the
move knight e2 which is more common
and now we arrive at our main plan here
for black which is this move b5
so this is sort of an improved version
of the line we just saw
in our previous game why is this an
improved version
well black is not really committing to
playing this move b5
and b takes c4 early early on first
black is getting developed with castle's
king side and playing d6 to stop e5
and only then sort of initiating this
play and that's why i think this is the
most common way for black to play
it just sort of makes the most sense and
black takes care of his own development
before coming after white's center
now here there are two main options for
white
and one of those options is knight f4
and one of those options
is knight to g3
and knight f4 is actually a little bit
more popular but as
i analyzed more and more variations i
think knight f4 is just a worse
version for white against all of the the
main moves here so i think
knight g3 is just a better move that's
my bold claim
uh so what can black do after knight g3
there are actually a few different
options that we're going to look at
and this is what i mean when i say that
these variations tend to get very
complex and very fluid
because black number one and what we're
going to start with can take on c4
go for positions like the one we saw in
our second
second example there number two black
can keep all the tension
and play the move bishop to b7 number
three
black cannot adopt a third position
entirely
with e takes d5 and number four black
can also just play a waiting move like
ricky rookie
8 or a6 and this is the thing that's
going to appear
in many you know subtle move order
differences
uh black is just always going to have
this variety of options variety of ways
to to take the game and it's the task of
the player with the white pieces
to ensure that you are well equipped
against all of the the options that
that black actually has so let's start
with b
take c4 and see how this compares to the
position we just saw
so once again bishop take c4 is going to
be the move
now in our first game we saw the move e
takes d5 in a position like this
bishop d5 knight d5 queen d5
and in that position the pawn was on d7
so knight c6 was forced
uh in this case black isn't just losing
thanks to the move queen b6 there's no
other way to save the rook but this one
is good enough
now if white of course were to take
bishop b7 traps the queen and would be
a disaster so what's going on
here for both sides let's
talk about the subtle differences
compared to the line we just looked at
well
of course black is now no longer forced
to give up this bishop and that's
a huge thing for black a3 now the move
bishop a5 is perfectly perfectly
playable
or black could even consider taking on
c3 now that we don't have
knight takes c3 in response so big plus
for black in that case black is also
castled king's side
and does not have to worry about
defending the c5 pawn so so far
so good for blacks just truly seems like
an improved version
of the position for black but that's not
totally true
uh white of course has an extra move in
in the form of knight g3
and whites is also
ready to immediately launch play on the
king side with knight h5 for example
and is also immediately ready to castle
king's side
so of white's various options i think
knight h5 is actually the best
but it is worth noting that kingside
castles is perfectly fine here for white
and you can arrive at that conclusion
by sort of thinking back to our first
variations
and thinking about the differences uh
thinking about who it favors
and here black structure is still just
quite bad
and because black structure is quite bad
white should be better if
you're able to complete development and
apply some pressure
to those weaknesses okay in the game
we're going to look at at knight h5
though because i i do think this is just
a better move
so knight h5 now knight d7 has been
played in every game that arrived here
and what's the point for white well
white can immediately play queen g5
force a weakness now by black and only
then castle king's side
and here white is just going to be
significantly better we have all the
same
structural weaknesses that i talked
about before
and we also have some ideas of trying to
checkmate black
on the dark squares after this move g6
and
finally black is very seriously going to
have to worry about this move
knight d5 in the near near future
so white is just better um that's why
he takes d5 not the most popular move
here
but as i mentioned in the previous line
when
black delays b takes c4 e takes d5 is is
now sort of not
forced anymore so what black can try to
do instead
is ratchet up the pressure on these two
diagonals immediately
the most popular way to do this is with
queen to a5 but i don't think this is
the best way to do this black can simply
castle
and now if black thinks he's going to go
pawn hunting
we actually get a pretty cool variation
here after the move queen
to b3 and if queen takes a one
white uh can simply develop this bishop
out i think
this is the most accurate square queen
e5 isn't going to be good enough
thanks to f4 trapping the queen so queen
takes f1 should be played king takes f1
and now black really does have to play
e5 and you wind up in this pretty
interesting position here
where white has a queen for the two
rooks but i do think this one
is going to favor white a little bit
believe it or not
why is that well black is a long long
ways away
from finishing development and
coordinating the pieces and especially
after the move
bishop to g5 we'll see that life gets
very very awkward
for black very very quickly if knight d7
knight f5 and this guy is looking
difficult
to defend okay
but i just wanted to mention that we
don't really have to be afraid of bishop
take c3 here
after the move king side castles so
bishop a6 is what was played in the one
game that made it this far
and here bishop takes a6 is perfectly
fine for
white notably the move bishop d2 has
been played a couple times here
and here i think bishop a6 is sort of
less good
for white because now if you take you
once again run into this problem where
white
can't castle king's side that's why i
think castle's king side is the most
consistent for
white and why we're not bothering to
defend this knight on c3
number one i think white gets an
advantage after bishop takes c3
and number two castles is just the most
consistent with
our you know way of thinking about the
position so far our structure is better
so we just want to finish development
and sort of
survive until we can prove it
in the game though bishop a6 was played
bishop takes a6
queen takes a6 and now after pawn takes
on e6 and pawn takes on e6
we get positions very very similar to
what we looked at
with takes on d5 a few times but now
black has this pawn on e6 rather than f7
that does change some things but that
doesn't really change white's plan
white is going to go first queen b3 and
apply some pressure to the d6 pawn and i
think it's just going to be
slightly better for example your key 8
bishop f4
hits this guy knight bd7 rick fd1
and black is already very much in danger
of just losing this pawn
uh losing this pawn outright uh so
i think once again white is going to be
better in these positions
uh just by a little bit but by enough
because white has a plan
and black's position is sort of on the
back foot
okay so what's the final move i want to
look at well i want to look at the
immediate bishop a6 as well
and here bishop takes a6 knight takes a6
is going to be played
and once again black has not
successfully prevented castling so white
is going to castle
and i think is going to be ever so
slightly better once again
thanks to that superior structure in the
center of
the board for example one game between
vladimir blues
and oliver dima killing
in the moscow open back in 2011 went
with knight c7
d takes e6 f takes e6 bishop f4
black goes c4 to open up this diagonal
but white is fine playing king h1
and here's where i'm going to leave it
because white once again
should be better with pressure on d6
so as far as plans here white really is
just looking to pressure the center
the center d6 pawn and potentially
launch an attack on the king's side as
well
with a timely move like e5
what is black going to do well black
should be looking to push the move d5 at
the right moment
but even this is not really going to
solve all of black's troubles
because the pawn is also going to be
also going to be a target on d5
as it is on d6
so here i think white is doing pretty
well
in every variation with the idea of b
takes c4 but as i said these lines are
complex
and this is just one of the many options
that
that black can take so with the next
game i want to take a look
at the sort of natural move e takes d5
and i can tell you practically
i end up in positions after e takes d5
sort of quite a bit
so in order to understand this one let's
take a look at a game
from the us champion u.s championship
between
sam shankland and alexander lenderman
so of course their game followed the
same path that we've been looking at
c5 d5 once again d6 and kingside castles
sam did play the move knight e2 now b5
by alexander lenderman
and we're arriving at our main position
of the night here
so we just looked at the lines of b take
c4 and i think most of those are going
to be pretty good for white after the
simple move
bishop takes c4 let's take a look at e
takes d5
i think while b takes c4 leads to
interesting positions where i think
white might be slightly better
i think he takes d5 is is sort of just
wrong
in this position uh for example c takes
d5 is gonna be white's response
and now black is not really in time to
deal with all the pressure on
the queen side uh in the game alex
linderman plays the move
a6 and i wanted to mention that we can
actually arrive here
through a different move order the move
a6 is also perfectly playable for black
here
and our response is going to be the same
with knight g3
and then here e takes d5 is one of the
most common options
c takes d5 and b5 is is a playable move
here
as well so wanted to highlight that that
there there's more than one path to this
position
but here ed5 cd5 and a6
so now i'm going to tell you sort of a
general thing
about this structure so whenever black
implements this move e takes d5
and c takes d5 almost always
white's response is going to be to
pressure these queen side pawns
with the move a4 so we're arriving at
our our third type of structure that's
uh that you can get
from these four c5 lines and once again
that's why these lines are so complex so
complicated
because there's just so many different
directions that the game could go
seemingly at any moment so of course
number one
we saw that immediate structure with
bishop takes c3 and similar structures
where black ever captures on
c3 number two we looked at what happens
with b
takes c4 in number three now we're
looking at what happens
if e takes d5 gets played and we're
focusing on this one specific instance
but i think next lecture we'll get into
some other instances
where black plays e takes d5 a little
bit faster or under different
circumstances
but regardless of all that regardless of
the circumstances
white's plan is going to remain pretty
consistent we want to pressure these
queen side pawns
thanks to our opponent for opening up
our bishop like this
we intend to make use of it with the
move a4
and the reason why this is a
particularly bad version
for black is black's just a couple tempe
short of
doing something useful in response to
this move a4
so the best move for black i think is
what um alexander lenderman found which
is the move bishop
a5 um why
is this the best response i think for
black
uh well also hold on here
i think leeches is doing some funny
things with the variations again
uh and in fact they are so i'm going to
jump really quick
because i realized leeches was messing
things up but the move bishop a5
once again is going to be our point so
why bishop a5 well it's the best way
for black to not lose a pawn and it's as
simple as that now a takes
b5 would be met by a b5 and you're
unable to capture here
for fear of this pin on the a file sort
of being turned against you
so bishop a5 good move and now bishop e2
is going to be the response we just
simply leave this tension here
and highlight the fact that um
that black is not going to have a good
way to respond
in the game lenderman tries this move b4
but uh we'll see this simply makes too
many light squared weaknesses
uh in black's camp uh alternatively
there is a game i believe from the pro
chess league that when it went with
knight bd7 between mohamed yarov and
rufang lee and here white's just going
to castle keep up this pressure
and black tries the alternate idea of c4
so there's sort of two ideas here to
deal with this pressure
one is to play b4 and one is to play c4
so let's actually start with this pro
chess league game and see what happens
after c4
uh well here mamadiara simply plays king
h1 to start with always a good idea to
vacate
this diagonal now after rook b8 we see
ab5
ab5 and now knight f5 and
the fact of the matter is while black
may have temporarily stunted this bishop
black is now going to have to commit a
variety of pieces
to making sure that nothing ever breaks
through and gets to this b5 square
and specifically here by the way black
is already immediately losing a pawn
on d6 and there really wasn't a good way
around this uh for example knight c5 is
what was played in the game
and here knight takes d6 is playable
immediately taking advantage of the fact
that the queen is overworked
but in the game mamadiar decided it was
time for an exchange sacrifice with rook
takes a5
and here white could take on d6 and be
much better with the two
uh with the central pawn duo in the game
mamadiar have actually
decided to reclaim the exchange with 97
knight c6 and was still
slightly better so wanted to highlight
this
why not c4 well c4 is a bit slow and it
doesn't really solve the problem of the
pressure on
the light squares black white was able
to take advantage with a knight f5
and king h1 combo when the d6 pawn was
sort of impossible to defend
blank just doesn't have the time to keep
it all together but it's important to
realize that c4 in general
is going to be a better idea than b4 it
just so happens here
that black doesn't really have the time
to get away with it so why not
b4 well that's when we arrive at this
game in the 2016 u.s championships
between shankland and lunderman
here sam plays this move knight to b1 c
knight bd7
kingside castles rookie eights and now
knight d2
sam reroutes this knight to d2 and it's
very clear now that these light squares
are a little bit weak knight e5 is
black's response trying to sort of
preemptively
get ahead of the move knight c4 but
here now i think you can uh just start
to borrow some ideas
from the benoni of course the bononi has
very similar structures to what you're
seeing right now
and here it is in fact just going to be
a good
version of those things for uh first sam
with the white pieces
so what's the most common idea in the
binoni well you break with this move f4
at the proper moment and it just so
happens that now
is that proper moment black occupies e5
sam kicks them off this square and after
knight g6
just place the move b3 which is a pretty
nasty
pretty nasty thing to do here just plays
b3
now knight c4 is coming and black's
position
is just going to be really really tough
uh just very very tough for black to
play this at all
uh so in the game bishop b6 was played
king h1
and black tries this move c4 to
sacrifice a pawn
and sam simply took it with with pawn
takes on c4
notably by the way knight takes c4 might
also lead to a big advantage
f5 might also lead to a big advantage um
but b takes c4 and white was a bit
better
in sam shanklin versus alexander
lenderman
i will say that this game did end in a
draw as you're seeing on the screen
but from the opening here especially
with this move knight takes c4
sam would have been very close close to
winning b takes c4 does give away a
little bit of the advantage
but knight takes c4 would have been
stellar
and just for example here knight c4
knight e4
knight e4 rookie 4 bishop d3 for example
we're back to e8 bishop b2 and
now the point is not so much about
winning a pawn
but this activity is just impossible to
uh
impossible to play against here white is
just sort of crushing
okay so questions
on this idea that we're talking about
here with e takes d5
in our main line position questions here
or on this structure in general
questions here
all right well let us keep on chugging
that
so we've talked about a few things now
we've talked about
the move b takes c4 in this position
we've talked about e takes d5 in this
position
now let's see what happens if black
tries the third main idea
of just pressuring this pawn on d5
and by the way i know this seems like a
lot
but i should point out that you're
probably going to be better prepared
than your opponents here
knight g3 has only been seen 34 times in
my database
and from here players with the black
pieces are honestly split b takes c4 has
been played nine times
bishop b7 has been played eight this has
been played five and some waiting move
has also been played like five to ten
times
so players with the black pieces really
don't know what's going on here
because clearly they haven't decided on
what the best way to play is
which is why we have so many wonderful
things to look at
but let us move on now and the game i'm
going to look at here
is between manuel mendel and
zdenek strakka straka something like
that
uh so let's just get to it not waste any
time just to refresh everybody's memory
we get here from the f3 nimzo for c5
we respond with d5 castles e4
d6 or d6 e4 castles now 92 is the main
variation
and we're focusing on the move b5 here
today the main
main line of this opening we follow up
with knight g3
rather than knight f4 and by the way you
saw
why i like knight g3 in some of the
previous variations
this knight is great at supporting the
center and threatening to jump to f5
this is why i like this move better than
knight f4
and now we're looking at this idea of
bishop to b7
and uh what's going on here well
black is sort of trying a even further
delayed
version of this idea of b takes c4
now rather than play b take c4 play an
eventual bishop a6
and try to trade off those bishops black
is just trying to
apply this pressure to d5 prematurely
rather than trade bishops black is just
going to
attempt to increase this pressure sort
of until it comes
to a breaking point for example if white
tries some developing move here
b takes c4 immediately and e takes d5
is already getting a bit awkward right
we don't really ever want to take this
with the pawn first of all this check is
awkward and second of all
this is really just giving us a weakness
and not the better structure we want
where we can attack the pawn
on d6 so that's black's threat
how are we going to respond to this
threat
well the best way that i have found is
with this move
a3 what's the point of a3
well the point is you are forcing this
bishop to make another decision
and we'll see that bishop a5 isn't
actually
the the perfect solution that black is
aiming for here
so uh a3 and i should mention by the way
d takes c6 is sort of a reasonable
alternative to this as
as well as we'll soon see so a3 and now
if black tries to take on c3
what's going on here well now after b
takes c4
uh we have sort of successfully planted
this pawn on the c4
square and white is going to have a nice
inner meso here of taking on e6
before taking back on c4 and now this
should be a structure you're a little
bit more familiar with
and by the way this one is slightly
different
from what we've seen before as it always
seems to be here black is able to play
the move d5
but really really importantly we also
have a pawn
on c3 now and that just further improves
the structure for white
because black is never going to be able
to push through to d4
sort of comfortably we just have too
much control over that square
so rather than bishop takes c3 every
time that a3 has been played
bishop a5 has been the response which i
think makes the most sense
and we're going to follow this up with d
take c6 which is of course why i'm
saying d takes e6
perfectly playable move here as well
with the idea
of a3 to follow it's just the same so
bishop a5
takes on e6 takes on e6 and here the
idea
is going to be to take on b5
so what's the point of our play well the
point is we're punishing
black for taking that extra tempo to
play bishop b7
and we're claiming that with this bishop
leaving the defense of the e6 pawn
we're forcing black to take
sub-optimally with the
f pawn and now just claiming an extra
pawn
on the b5 square in
all the games this has appeared black
responds with the immediate d5 which i
think is correct
if black doesn't respond with d5 white
is
just going to continue develop
developing white doesn't need any
serious threats
right now the structure favors white
unless black can do something immediate
fortunately fortunately for black you
can do something immediate here
which is the move d5 so at first glance
this looks pretty scary
i would be scared if i had the white
pieces here and in fact i've had similar
uh well at least one similar game to uh
to this exact position
where there was a pin on my knight
bearing down
on the queen side and d5 d4 was a very
serious threat
fortunately though white does have a
tactical solution to this
thanks to this f pawn being drawn away
and that solution is to capture on d5
now e takes d5 is the move that makes
the most sense
since knight takes d5 would just be met
by a bishop d2
so e takes d5 and then simply bishop e2
completely ignoring the threat of d4
black now can and should play the move
d4 but white has this nice tactical
refutation
of b2 to b4 now how does this actually
work why can't black just take twice
well after takes queen b3 check
yeah and yeah queen b3 check is the
tactic i should note that you
don't really want to take here first
because then you're going to be by
a surprise knight d5 so queen b3 check
first
should be played and now if knight d5
you can actually just take this
and this is white's response to to
black's idea here
now black is going to play the move king
h8 or
knight d5 does turn out to still be
playable now in the game we're focusing
on
king h8 was the idea and i think it's
probably the best idea for black
but if knight d5 we're simply going to
capture go bishop c4
and now after king h8 we just sort of
get a simplified version of the same
with either castles immediately or a
takes b4 i like castles we'll say
and we're gonna get a pretty similar
thing to what we see in the game
but with a few more simplifications so
let's focus on the game which is king h8
now a takes b4 is the idea the bishop
comes back to c7
and now white has to waste a little bit
of time with knight to a4
okay so complicated stuff so far
complicated stuff but there's one tactic
that you should keep in mind and that's
this idea of b4 against the big center
now this game continues with knight b to
d7 we get king's side castles
and knight e5 by black and now bishop d3
uh and i'll play just a couple more
moves before stopping to talk we see net
h5
and so sorry no i won't play a couple
more moves because black sort of
initiates
um a pretty crazy tactical idea here
that that just
simply does does not work so
why does black initiate this crazy
tactical idea
well once again we're in a position
where somehow
white seems to have gotten into a a
favorable structure
what do i mean by that well for the
moment white is up a pawn
but even if one of these pawns drops off
this d4 pawn
is going to be a target once again so
what's the idea if black sort of does
nothing
say queen e8 for example well white is
just going to play the move knight c5
gonna retreat with the move queen c2 i'm
going to bring this bishop out to b2
bring the rook to the center and be
better thanks to
the strong strong structure so black in
the game
felt the need to do something immediate
which maybe a move like queen eight
would have been better served
than than what black opted to go for in
in the game but i think here white is in
fact going to be a little bit better
uh thanks to the structure thanks to the
d4 pawn thanks to
active rooks for white finishing
development once again
better structure so in the game black
tries knight h5
and i wanted to include this move go
over this move
because this is the crazy type of stuff
you're going to play against
in your own games now i mentioned i
myself had a game
in a similar position to this and that
was actually against fm doug
eckert and i ended up winning that game
but i
was in fact lost at some point thanks to
a tactic
similar to this so i really think it's a
good idea to expose you guys to this
before we uh before we move on so net h5
crazy move right free knight and that's
what white
thought in the game but then it gets
followed up with the move
knight takes f3 check and you start to
realize
that your once solid control over these
light squares turns out to be
pretty shaky after all so knight takes
f3
and then in the game white tried rook
takes f3 which does in fact
give up the advantage g takes f3 would
have
been i think better for white
when white is in fact going to be
maintaining the the extra piece
bishop takes h2 check is a good try
but after this move white has i believe
king to g2
when uh things should be should be good
for um for white or am i wrong did i mix
something up here
i might have mixed something up um
okay i thought gf3 bishop h2 queen h4
queen e6 is the key idea and i mean
things are going to stay crazy here but
in my analysis i think if you let the
engine run here
it ends up saying white is better
uh but in the game we saw rook takes f3
instead now bishop takes h2
king takes h2 rook takes f3 g takes f3
and the game ends in a draw
pretty quickly thereafter with queen to
h4 so really important idea
to to keep an eye on here and this turns
out to be a correspondence game i didn't
even realize that
that's probably why both players played
so well and agreed to a draw at the end
so what was the point of me showing you
this knight h5 move well the point is
be on the lookout man this bishop can be
sort of terrifying so while the
structure i think does
favor white i think this is true it's
very very important that you keep an eye
on the light squares around your king
or you may fall victim to tactics very
very similar
to uh to this now as far as opening
theory is concerned
i don't think you really need to
memorize all this the key point here
i think is that a3 takes and takes
results in a a pretty reasonable
position for
white and after this threat of d5 d4
keep in mind you have this tactic of b4
with queen b3 check
to sort of save yourself and finish
development
from there be careful of the light
squares around your king
and with that i believe we are running
short on time
so let me just quickly recap everything
we've done today
we started our discussion of the move 4
c5
and as i stated before c5 is a move
that is sort of very complex because the
game can go
in a wide variety of different
directions there are many different
structures to be aware of
and many different ways the game can
continue so first we looked at what
happened
back in the 90s when everybody thought
this was the best structure of all time
and we saw that white eventually plays
h4 and black is left without a plan
we then looked at what happens if black
tries the immediate b5 and take on c4
and we discovered that this structure
turns out to just be
a little bit better for white and white
can really prove it with this move a3
uh as seria ganguly demonstrated
the point is you get rid of this bishop
black has all the weaknesses and white
is able to complete development
and then we took a look at the main line
of the opening which goes with d6
side castles and only then this move b5
and here sorry not bishop d3 not bishop
d3 knight e2
and then b5 and what we talked about
here
is that g3 is the best square for the
knight because it defends e4 and
threatens to jump into the f5 square
and we talked about black's main options
here
of b takes c4 e takes d5
and bishop b7 so that is where we're
going to call it today
for a sneak peek of tomorrow i am or
it's not tomorrow
next week i am going to be mentioning
the lines that go with b5 here
when white can go directly with e5 and
the game gets crazy
and i am also going to be talking about
a subtle move order switch up by black
which is this move rook e8 thankfully
due to our move order it's not going to
change the way that we play
but we will once again arrive at this
main position
or arrive at very similar positions that
are also
worth taking a look at and lastly we are
going to also analyze some side moves
here for example to move a6
the immediate e takes d5 and even a
knight h5 so all of that in store for
next week
and maybe we'll even have a part three
on this move for c5
there's just way too much going on and
it's going to take some time to cover it
so hopefully this helps you unpack a
little bit of what's going on
in the 4c5 variation with this dark
squared plan for black
there is a lot to know but if you think
about it based on these different
structures
you can really boil it down to a few
different main ideas that you have to
remember
thank you all very much for watching if
you're watching live please head over to
the twitch channel for a special edition
of tactics time
and if you're watching the youtube
version or if you've just had enough of
chess for the night
once again thank you for watching as
always my name is caleb denby
and i will see you next time
you